hello so the last couple of videos i've
been doing a lot of uh well we've been
doing a lot of project emotion we'll
keep doing some projectile motion but uh
i think
it may have seemed more confusing than
it really is because i kept everything
in terms of variables and we you know we
worked with the formulas and the
variables but what i want to do is is
take all that all those things that that
we've that hopefully i've i've taught
you or that you've had exposure to over
the last couple of videos and just do a
bunch of problems because i think this
is all about experience and and getting
the intuition and just chugging through
a lot of problems so let's just do a
let's do a straightforward one
kind of going back to the ball throwing
game so let's say i throw a ball
so i throw a ball
straight straight up
throw a ball up
that the total time
the ball is in the air
is
i don't know let's say it's seven
seconds
seven seconds
so
how fast did i throw it up
how fast
did
i throw
straight up
not throw up or
how fast i throw the ball up
and then
how high did it go
how high
did
it
go
so i could you know we figured out a
bunch of formulas and we could plug it
straight into those formulas and solve
this problem in 10 seconds
or probably more like two seconds but
what i want to do is just actually go
through the same logic we went through
to get the formulas but i'll work with
the numbers and i'll show you this isn't
something we even have to memorize
formulas
so it took seven seconds right the ball
took seven seconds to go all the way to
go up
and then to go down right
and assuming no air resistance it took
the same amount of time to go to its
peak as it took to go down right so it
took
so it took
it took
3.5 seconds
to go up
to go up right
it took
time is 3.5 seconds and then it that's
3.5 and then it took another 3.5 seconds
to go down
right 3.5
so it took 3.5 seconds to get his peak
so what does that tell me well it tells
me that in 3.5 seconds the ball went
from whatever the initial velocity it
was when it left my hand the ball went
from
you know
v
v sub i is equal to you know whatever it
went from that initial velocity
this is the ball this isn't a number
and then by the time it got to the top
to the kind of the peak of its travel it
got to
zero velocity so i'll call that v sub f
or the final velocity right it went from
it went from whatever speed i threw it
at to zero in 3.5 seconds
right
so now we could just use i mean we don't
even have to use a formula we can kind
of think of it intuitively how fast am i
decelerating how fast am i decelerating
so so what well i'm decelerating at the
rate of gravity right i mean we know
that because that's what's slowing down
the ball so we know that acceleration is
equal to minus 10
meters per second squared
and so what do we do well acceleration
is the same thing as the change in
velocity
the
is is the same acceleration times time
is the same thing as the change in
velocity or the change in velocity
divided by time is acceleration so let's
let's say that so change in velocity
well the change in velocity
change in velocity is equal to the final
velocity
minus the initial velocity
and that equals acceleration times time
so minus 10
meters per second squared
meters per second squared i'll stick
with the units this time times time so
it did that in three and a half seconds
times
3.5 seconds
so this seconds cancels out with one of
the seconds in the denominator here
and so let's see so i get
minus vi
is equal to
minus 350
meters per second
right minus 10 times i don't know that's
that's 3.5 not 35 so it's minus 35
meters per second something was looking
suspicious
minus 35 meters per second and then of
course you know multiply both times by
negative 1. and the initial velocity is
equal to 35 meters per second
that wasn't too bad you don't even have
to really you know do it formally like
this you just say well you know i'm
throwing it at some speed
right it took
of the total time it takes half of that
time for it to go to zero right so i
threw it at some speed and it took three
and a half seconds to go to zero
and it's decelerating at this speed
right
so every second it's getting 10 meters
per second slower every second i go it's
gonna it's getting 10 meters per second
slower so if it took three and a half
seconds
then i must to go to zero
i must have started off at 35 meters per
second
if that confuses you use the formula but
i want to give you a sense that you can
kind of just just use your intuition
right every second every second it
travels in the air it's getting it's
getting 10 meters per second slower
it took three and a half seconds to go
from whatever speed you threw it at to
zero
so
it must have gone it must have started
off at 35 meters per second right after
at t equals one it was going 25 meters
per second
at t equals 2 it was going 15 meters per
second
at t equals 3
the ball is going straight up at
5 meters per second and at t equals 3.5
the ball is stationary it's right at the
top and then it starts decelerating
downwards
let's do some more problems
i don't like these these colors let me
switch to
to something nicer
okay let's do another classic you know
oh i and also in that problem i didn't
figure out how how high the ball went so
once again
you know the total time the total travel
time is seven seconds
right we know the acceleration is minus
10 meters
per second squared and we know that the
initial velocity now we figured it out
is 35 meters per second
so to figure out how high it went so
let's just draw that part so the ball is
going up
right
and we figured out just in its upward
portion to go from to go from vi
is equal to 35
meters per second to let's call this vf
is equal to zero meters per second
it took the ball
3.5 seconds
right because this is half of its travel
time then it took another 3.5 seconds to
come straight down
well we could just use our
our fairly straightforward formula that
you know change in distance is equal to
the average velocity times time
right and this is you know this this
should be pretty intuitive to you it
shouldn't even be viewed as a formula
hopefully it's starting to be viewed as
as maybe even common sense but anyway so
what was the average velocity well the
average velocity is just the average of
your initial velocity and your velocity
at the top of of the curve so it's
that's zero so the average of 35 and
zero is just 35 divided by two so it
equals
over 2
and then what's the time
3.5 seconds
and i could use my trusty calculator
provided by windows
divided by 2
times
3.5
is equal to
61.25 meters
pretty easy
and so i hopefully you're realizing that
you know we used a lot of formulas and
things and the formulas were getting you
know they're they're all over the page
last time but when you actually used to
do it with numbers it's it's it's not so
bad
in the next video now i'm going to do
just keep doing a bunch more physics
problems because i think you're probably
tired of this
this this ball throwing business see you
soon